podcast man you already know shout out
to the homie representing Kansas City
Missouri you can see them on a ton of
[__] wilding out season 19 to 20 out
right now his new song is out Bobby J's
here that's the let's do it let's get to
it man
okay
[Music]
okay yeah
oh okay let's let's go yeah okay let's
go look okay these [__] ain't [__]
with me okay got a bad [__] I don't get
no [__] if you cheat I told that little
[__] if she [__] on that [__] she
better not [__] him for free children
I'm Capital Peter where the life you
[__] with a G huh be your double to the
B positive feed to the E told him I'm
repping KC for sure huh yeah KC MO huh
816 [__] hell I'm from the three four
yeah 34 the monkey in my pots yeah put a
whole lot of game in me and now with
them Ops uh I ain't [__] with no Ops no
I ain't [__] with no cops um I can get
on that thought yeah and she gonna give
me your drop here we gonna spin your
block yeah Shooters gonna send shots
yeah we're gonna spin one more again on
to make sure your partner get dry yeah
um Hold Up Wait boy I got swag I'm
dripping on them hold up hey pocket full
of Blues hold like I'm creeping on them
hold up wait okay I told them [__]
that I'm Different Homie Over the Top of
the Dome I ain't come here with no
riddance homie this for real Bobby J got
the skill they know that I'm built to
kill they know that I'm built for real
they know that I'm built toughest deal
they know that I came and they know
Arcane is real they know that they know
the drill they know what it is they know
that I got a career they know that it's
on the hill and I've been getting chips
since I said Disney money which I'm
still spending Disney money they already
know Bobby J getting plenty of money
[__] I've been getting plenty of money
Hold Up Wait might pull away this [__]
honey might pull up with your opinion
honey hold up wait they know that I'm
pimping honey I might get some pimping
money I might come through like just
give me hundreds baby girl just keep it
with me matter of fact they know I'm in
a new building and they know I'll keep
it send it cause it's a stick up in it
and I'm riding I'm on probation they
can't see me in it gotta swerve and I
get on them police they know that I
gotta leave them I already know that I
don't believe them they already know
that they talking that game of [__] but
I swear that I don't believe them Bobby
J you can ask about me in any City [__]
I'm the reason that them [__] smoking
real zai they already know that Bobby J
been the reason [__] that ain't no lie
hold on wait I've been having them peas
and I've been moving that let me stop
talking that might get on [__]
fans they be moving traps Hold Up Wait
they already know if [__] shoot at me
then I'm shooting back hold on wait they
already know that Bobby J get it all
right
[Laughter]
yes sir hey I know you just watched the
new freestyle guess what we're dropping
them every week sometimes more than once
a week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week